it's more expensive to live in Hong Kong
than anywhere in the world Hong Kong has
been ranked the least affordable housing
market in the world eight years in a row
and by a long shot
housing prices are now almost 20 times
more than annual income that means that
a household making fifty thousand US
dollars would on average be looking for
a house that cost nine hundred and
eighty thousand dollars and it's getting
really bad hundreds of thousands of
residents now squeeze into incredibly
small apartments most of them no bigger
than a parking space so these are K
chao-li's which basically fit one person
and their belongings and they basically
stacked these in a room in order to fit
as many people as they can in the room
and yet the price per square foot for
these smaller houses just keeps shooting
up I visited these homes to try to piece
together an explanation for this trend
and to meet the people who are being
squeezed by the world's least affordable
real estate market
[Music]
there are now tens of thousands of
people in this city who lived in spaces
that are between 75 and 140 square feet
for some perspective a typical parking
space in the u.s. is 120 square feet
[Music]
see ya right don't get me wrong one of
the most common strategies for small
space living is this subdivided house
model this big space that's been divided
up into a bunch of tiny little living
spaces as people basically have room for
a bed and a table and a few belongings
hey-yah would be the Philadelphia County
okay oh you know could be a chung kuo
dealer God he's so ality like yeah I'm
not like oh god not yet
what makes this model work so they have
a bigger communal space where they're
able to have their cooking and their
washing in the bathroom open to everyone
so that they can save space and save
money in their actual living quarters so
this is the kitchen for this space which
is shared by four families I'm going
outside without one thank you Santos
you'll see the world
mocha O'Dell doesn't go long the
tempting explanation here or why the
prices are so high is land scarcity you
know seven half-million people crammed
into this series of islands it's gonna
drive up the prices the same story in a
lot of places that have run out of land
that are in high demand in San Francisco
or New York City okay this might be this
story in New York City in San Francisco
but is hong kong actually running out of
land let's see what the drone says about
this flying over hong kong you start to
see that while yes there's a very dense
urban landscape there's also a whole lot
of green space government land use data
says that seventy five percent of the
land in hong kong is not developed now
some of that is mountainous and rocky
and not easy to build on but certainly
not all of it
[Music]
so I posed this question about density
to two experts one is a Hong Kong
citizen and the other is a 30-plus year
resident both are advocates for better
urban design our high prices primarily
the result of land scarcity no no no
there's a land-use issue we could also
land as being it efficiently used or
conserved the problem isn't the shortage
of land the problem is bad Land
Management land use Land Management what
these experts are referring to is that
of all the land in Hong Kong only three
point seven percent is zoned for urban
housing but it's not because of
mountains it's because of policy and
this gets to the heart of the
explanation of why more and more people
are living in homes the size of parking
spaces the first thing to note if you
want to understand the real explanation
is that the government owns all of the
land in Hong Kong well all except for
this one church that the British built
here when they rule it back in the 1800s
and it kind of just escaped the whole
government owns all the land thing so
the government owns all the land and it
leases it out to developers usually for
50 years in an auction process where the
highest bidder gift the contract with
such scarce and valuable land zoned for
housing real estate companies more and
more of them coming from mainland China
with lots of money will Duke it out in
these options and we'll end up at an
astronomically high price
like this plot of land that was just
leased out for 2.2 billion dollars which
shed an all-time record for the most
expensive land of released by the Hong
Kong government to a developer so the
way that government zones and leases
land is the first part of this the other
part of this explanation has a lot to do
with taxes if you're the type of person
who navigates away from this video when
you hear the word tax policy stay with
me here this police loves low taxes it's
a great place to do business because the
corporate tax is low no value-added tax
no sales tax free market economics low
taxes that's embedded into the fabric of
this place we put all those low taxes
doing their work building up those
skyscrapers slapping on those Bank logos
all over town so if the government has
any revenue from taxes it really needs
it from another source and in the case
of Hong Kong that source is land sales
there's a lot of the government revenues
here driven by land and revenues and
it's about 30% of the government's
public financing income the government
of Hong Kong can lease out this land to
developers at astronomical prices make a
ton of revenue from that and not have to
raise taxes on the people of the
corporation that reside here and they
still proudly retain their
as the freest economy on earth what this
means is that Hong Kong government
doesn't have a huge incentive to free up
more land and lower prices but while
this current arrangement of bidding and
auctions is really good for a revenue
for the government and good for the
market generally it's not super good for
the people of Hong Kong all the small
spaces this is easily the most cramped
these are coffin homes today I asked for
your just a quick question about your
living space the government is slowly
working on this problem
year after year new policies come in
that are meant to fix this but they're
slow to change mainly because they have
an incentive to keep the status quo as
it is out here at this industrial
complex in Hong Kong I met with a guy
named Eric Wong a local inventor and
businessman who has seen a business
opportunity in the midst of this space
crisis
Eric grew up in Hong Kong and has been
thinking about small space living for a
long time it's a hyotei so I guess the
outcome so do not make that all hi okay
my question your life panel son should
my dad but CHR come on tough guys are
childhood climate Oh has Wi-Fi his
capsules come in one or two persons
sizes and are meant to provide a more
efficient and hygienic version of the
cage and coffin homes all at a
relatively low price down here there's a
little box where you can put all your
valuables and so the mirror lights this
reading lights but these capsules is
innovative as they are really just put a
bandaid on this housing problem
they don't serve as a real solution a
real solution would need to come from
something that's much less profitable
and fun to look at government policy and
zoning reform that will free up more
land and put the interests of the people
above the interests of the market but
until the government can make that
happen people in Hong Kong will continue
to squeeze into smaller and smaller
spaces
[Laughter]